depuis mon jour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
à la rencontre au sommet aujourd'hui à
rome entre emmanuel macron et joe biden
s'est bien emmanuel macron qui reçoit le
président américain l'ambassade de
france alors que doit-on attendre de
cette rencontre
bah écoutez là au delà du symbolisme
vous avez raison de rappeler la
présidence française tu peux aussi
françaises je ne sors pas encore ma
présence française de l'union européenne
a été très insistante pour que cette
réunion ait lieu en territoire français
il fut question de la villa médicis il
fut question du palais farnèse
finalement c'est la ville après la
partie le siège de l'ambassade de france
auprès du saint siège on peut je pense
pas trop en attendre pour plusieurs
raisons premièrement parce que le
président français et le président
américain se sont dit à peu près tout ce
qu'il avait à se dire lors du dernier la
dernière conversation téléphonique qui
l'ont eu car depuis il ne s'est pas
passé grand chose au delà des paroles
d'apaisement de la nécessité de
renforcer l'autonomie stratégique mais
après tout de quelle autonomie
stratégique parlons nous parlons nous
réellement d'une autonomie stratégique
en dehors de l'otan il me semble que la
ministre allemande de la défense à
négrette rappelé karl baumer a
d'une certaine façon réduit la position
française au sein de l'organisation donc
de l'alliance atlantique en évoquant le
fait que la pression française n'était
pas partagé les pays européens donc le
président et mène à macron arrive avec
un agenda qui lui est propre domestique
comme vous l'avez dit le président
américain arrive aussi avec un agenda
touristique il ne faut pas s'attendre à
de grandes avancées à l'occasion de ce
g20 tout temps que ces g20 à agir
concomitamment avec l'ouverture de la
cop16 de kasso dimanche prochain et on
voit bien que la communauté
internationale le g20 par julian est
parti commenté unis
il faut rappeler également que les deux
tiers des émissions de gaz à effet serre
saute le produit par les pays du g20
mais qu'en l'absence physique du
président du pin chinois ou du président
russe les discussions ont pour une
certaine façon être que mon ce n'est
comme n'étant pas forcément
si déterminé que ça aboutir aux
objectifs que s'était fixés la france
avec l'accord de paris de décembre 2015
alors le dossier
2 du contrat du siècle va sûrement être
abordée entre emmanuel macron et joe
biden mais il ya d'autres dossiers sur
lesquels emmanuel macron souhaiterait
avancé on pense notamment à ce concept
de souveraineté européenne qui est cher
au président français qui souhaite
peut-être obtenir voilà l'appui des
états unis
c'est contradictoire comment peut-on
parler d'autonomie stratégique en
obtenant l'appui des états unis le
principe de l'autonomie stratégique
c'est de ses distances et les états unis
a besoin de l'appui des états unis on a
besoin d'eux certes d'avoir la certitude
que les états unis comprennent que
l'autonomie stratégique doit se faire de
manière européenne l'autonomie
stratégique du point de vue américain et
rsa que les pays européens consacrent
plus de 2% ou en l'occurrence 2% à des
minima de leur budget aux dépenses
militaires pour une raison simple pour
acheter du matériel américain
l'autonomie stratégique de l'europe au
sein de l'otan le tome i stratégique de
l'europe avec l'ambition d'acheter du
matériel américain me semble loin de
l'idée que certains se font de cette
notion d'indépendance stratégique cher
au président français comme vous l'avez
rappelé c'est la raison pour laquelle
les deux hommes ne parlent pas le même
langage
le président et mme hélène macro zone
sans doute je crois avec honnêteté
s'émanciper d'une tutelle qui est la
nôtre au sein d'un certain nombre
d'alliances l'union européenne
évidemment le lion et l'alliance
atlantique nous oblige à parler de
manière convergente mais il faut aussi
rappeler un autre élément qui commence à
monter singulièrement à mesure que la
rencontre a lieu le président obama
qu'on ne parle pas au nom de l'union
européenne nous ne sommes pas encore
dans la présidence française l'union
européenne c'est bien un escroc veliki
le président le pr ministre slovène l'a
rappelé et il ya de cela quelques heures
donc je ne pense pas vraiment que le
dossier de l'autonomie stratégique
avance par contre les dossiers qui vont
avancer sont ce qui avait été décidé
avant le sommet du g20 en l'occurrence
la taxation à hauteur de 15% des
multinationales il y à un accord entre
les états unis et l'europe sur ce point
cela a été validé lors de la dernière
réunion du g7 en grande bretagne et à
l'occasion de l' ocde d'ailleurs cela va
être confirmée cazaux l'assemblée
générale de ces quelques semaines et
puis bien évidemment due à un certain
nombre de sur lequel c'est vrai la
france etats unis pourront dialoguer de
manière plus concertée notamment la
lutte contre le terrorisme et plus
particulièrement la tante de la france
d'un soutien plus déterminés des états
unis au sahel un mot également sur ce
sommet dieu et du g20 du g20 qui va donc
s'ouvrir demain en présence de joe biden
d'autres dirigeants ne seront pas là ils
seront présents par visioconférence le
président chinois le président russe
également comment faut-il interpréter
leur absence physique
à écouter c'est là aussi de l'ordre du
symbolisme le président vallières
poutine et le président jean ping
s'était rendu à l'occasion du sommet de
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai qui s'est tenue il ya quelques
semaines à douchanbé validant
l'intégration pleine et entière de
l'iran donc on a de plus en plus
l'impression qu'un certain nombre de
puissances orientale délaisse ses
instances et pourtant le g20 est une
instance plus concertée en tout cas plus
équilibré puisque c'est un mélange où un
rassemblement il faut aussi le rappeler
près de 90% du pib mondial et près de
85% de du commerce mondial donc
évidemment c'est une instance plus
équilibrée en tout cas nettement plus
équilibré que le g7 au delà de l'absence
de que vous avez mentionné il ya aussi
la présence très symbolique de la
chancelière angela merkel qui va d'une
certaine façon présenter son successeur
puisque non seulement elle vient pour
son dernier sommet international
sera aussi présent à glasgow d'ici
quelques heures alors en écosse mais
elle gère accompagné du futur chance
elle est chaude donc il ya aussi
beaucoup de symbolisme dans cette
culture ligier 20 le président mène
maintenant d'ailleurs doit s'entretenir
avec narendra modi le pré ministre
indien c'est l'inde qui va succéder à
l'italie à l'année prochaine pour la
présidence du g20 et il sera aussi
question de l'inde au pacifique et du
contrat australien puisqu'il est
fortement question que la france puisse
accélérer son soutien à l'exportation de
nos sous marins l'un que nous avait
acheté six sous-marins scorpène en 2005
le président serin diaa s'est montré
très intéressé par l'achat de 3
seulement trois sous-marins
supplémentaires ce qui aura 2 a
valeur de symbole à mesure que
l'australie évidemment confirme son
éloignement du contre un des douze soir
à que nous l'avions vendus en 2015 merci
beaucoup et emmanuel depuis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l'institut
prospective et sécuritaire d'europe